[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
tuesday june 21st i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal
[Music]
short form videos snippets of advice
dancing pranks that run no more than a
few minutes and often just a few seconds
have become the latest big battleground
in social media
tiktok popularized short form videos and
it's been the front runner for some time
but as we told you last week it's facing
increased competition from rival service
google's youtube shorts
the company says shorts is now reaching
more than one and a half billion users a
month
so how did shorts which launched in 2020
get to this point so quickly
how do creators feel about using it and
what is youtube's end game in growing
this part of its platform
joining us to discuss all of this is our
social media reporter salvador rodriguez
hi sal thanks for being here hey zoe
thanks for having me
so start us off with a bit of background
why did youtube decide to launch shorts
in the first place and i mentioned it
was you know gaining on tick tock's
popularity but just how popular is it
yeah from what we can tell youtube
shorts might be second place in this
new type of social media content you
know in the us
we talked with the folks over at inmar
intelligence and they found that youtube
shorts is picked as the number two
preferred service for this type of short
form video and that's only gained since
the last time that they did this survey
back in september
for youtube they decided to go in on
this type of content because it just
made a ton of sense for them they're the
original
video platform of the internet right but
also you know i spoke with a lot of
creators and some of them pointed out
that in many ways tick tock poses a
threat to youtube youtube decided to
launch its shorts in india why did it
pick that market and what's it been like
for shorts growing there
yeah i think the reason they started in
india is because just before youtube
launched there in september 2020 a few
months prior india had actually banned
tik tok and several other chinese apps
they cited national security concerns as
the reason for doing that and that just
created a huge opening for youtube to go
in to a really huge market and you know
get started test out this new type of
thing but really gain a foothold in that
market and that's something that from
our reporting we can tell is continuing
to carry them today you know we spoke
with one creator his name is jonathan
lyons he uh he dresses up as a as a huge
rat and he posts these videos on youtube
shorts he told us that almost 80 percent
of his views are coming from india
and even more of his views come from
nearby country so it's really become a
stronghold for youtube
now as they grow and they've hit this
huge mark of 1.5 billion users you know
that's something that you can really
build upon and what they're really going
to have to do is make sure that they
build up that audience here in the us
because
they're doing good with india they're
doing good with older americans but when
it comes to advertising which is really
the next step the most desirable
audience for advertisers are those young
americans those young consumers that
they can you know grab a hold of and
keep us customers for a lifetime i want
to pick up on something you said you
know youtube shorts is popular with
older americans i mean why would
americans kind of 45 and up be
gravitating towards youtube shorts
youtube already had more than two
billion people who go to youtube
regularly
and they've also built out a ton of
analytics tools for creators so they can
get a sense of how well their videos are
doing um who's watching them and from
where and basically youtube took those
two things
and turned them into success you know
they've been around since 2005 so they
have older users at this point
and i think
one reason why if you're an older
american
and you're going to youtube shorts
instead of tick tick-tock it simply
comes down to
changing your habits you know you've
probably been going to youtube for more
than a decade and getting into tik-tok
it's not really hard but it still
requires that someone download one more
app sign up for one more account but i
guess the big question is how does
youtube transition you know from the
older viewers and from a big indian
market to a global market with younger
viewers
yeah i think it's gonna take time but
i've also noticed you know as a regular
consumer watching tv i've noticed that
they've been you know doing more and
more marketing just the other day i saw
youtube ran an ad for pride month and
they were saying like hey you know it's
pride month like show your pride by
posting a youtube short and every
every video that you post you know will
make one more donation to you know some
group involved in pride and i think like
those type of strategies will just pump
more and more content into that youtube
shorts pipeline and what they really
need to get to is to a place where their
videos are the ones that are starting
trends and really you know hitting that
cultural cachet because at this point in
time that's a big reason that tick tock
leads in this market
you've spoken to a bunch of creators who
are using youtube shorts and what have
they said about the experience of using
it
yeah well the creators they love the
analytics that they get with youtube
short so they can go in there and they
can see how old are my users what
geography are they coming from are they
on android are they on iphone they can
you know really get into the nitty
gritty of what's going on and that helps
them figure out you know the formulas
for
which videos are going to work which
videos are going to get me views and
another thing that folks love about
youtube shorts is that it just has
another one of those classic google
strengths which is that it's way easier
to search for a video on youtube shorts
than it is to search for a video on tick
tock or instagram reels the biggest
criticism though that we heard so far
from creators about youtube shorts is
that
when it comes to actually applying
special effects to videos
that is where youtube shorts is lacking
most i mean that's from the creator side
from from youtube side from google side
this has to be about you know ad revenue
right i mean how profitable are youtube
shorts for the company
yeah well right now it's not
particularly profitable just because
they haven't prioritized advertising
just yet
it wasn't until last month that they
finally rolled out ads globally for
youtube shorts but even now it's still
you know experimental and they're only
starting to ramp it up but certainly
that's going to be the direction that
they start heading in and they really do
need to get that going just because you
know
more recently their revenue growth has
been flagging as of late
all right that was our reporter salvador
rodriguez thanks for speaking with us
sal yeah thanks for having me
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website
wsj.com and if you like our show please
rate and review it you can do that
wherever you get your podcasts i'm zoe
thomas for the wall street journal
thanks for listening
[Music]